-You talk a lot about name
in your special.
And there's this wonderful bit
And you have one name
that you believe
rises above all the other names.
-That's right.
I'm sure we all agree.
-Yeah, I think we call agree
-It's Susan, obviously.
-Yeah. Yeah.
Why do you love Susan so much?
-Susan's in control.
-Yeah.
-Susan's not going to take
any nonsense.
-Yep.
-You know,
Susan is going into rooms.
She has a briefcase,
and people are like,
"Get her a table
for that briefcase."
-Yeah, I see.
-Yeah.
And then she's like...
[ Laughs ]
..."I'm going to hold on to it."
-Gotcha.
-You know?
-So, you feel there's a real -
Names right away --
you, like, know what they are.
-That's right.
-You know who the person is.
What is Seth like?
I know you know me,
but, like, what --
You probably know
a lot of Seths.
-I don't know that many Seths.
-Oh, really?
You don't know that many Seths
-Yeah.
And you're my favorite one
-Oh, thank you very much.
-You're welcome.
You're -- Mm.
Here's what I think about
the name Seth.
It's gentle.
-Okay.
-"Hey, I don't want to
play volleyball.
I want to play Nuke 'Em."
I want to have fun."
-Yeah.
-"I'm not trying to spike it
in your face.
I'm your friend. I'm Seth.
-Yeah. Thank you.
-Yeah.
-I've never wanted to
play volleyball.
-No!
-And, by the way, I like whe
a volleyball's around.
-Yeah, but for catching.
-Or, like, let's keep it up.
Let's all just, like -- Let'
never let it hit the ground.
-Let's Keep it Up
is the best game,
like, when you have
a beach ball
and you're like, "45, 46!"
-Yeah. And then you just set
an arbitrary number,
and you're like, "We will stay
here until we get it."
Or not.
-Yeah, totally.
-There's very -- There is no
stakes to this.
-See? That's your name.
You just dug into this.
-I'm very, very happy
about this.
-Yeah, it's a
friendly, friendly zone.
-We -- I so enjoyed
last time you were here.
We talked about your love-hate
relationship with brides,
who, on their wedding day,
just decide
or they have planned to sing
a song to their groom.
-Yeah.
-And the groom doesn't
know, often.
-Yeah.
-And, certainly, no one
at the wedding knows.
-Sometimes, it seems like
the groom knows,
but he was, like,
not allowed to say no.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
I mean, I just think
it's such a --
just a totally interesting move.
There are brides that sing their
way down the aisle.
-Yeah.
-And you just
can't get enough of it.
-I cannot get enough.
They're often literal.
At this point, I feel that I can
make up the bride's song,
even if I'm not the bride.
-Okay, so, just for fun,
I will give you a groom's name
and some details
about the groom.
-Great.
-This is nothing
that you've heard before.
-Yeah.
-Okay, Rufus.
-Rufus.
-And Rufus loves --
He's a big football fan.
He loves the Buffalo Bills
-Mm-hmm.
-And his favorite food
is chicken fingers.
-Great.
-Yeah.
-Okay, so, imagine, like,
big, big dress.
She's got a wireless mic.
She's coming down a
spiral staircase,
walking towards the groom,
who's like, "Whoa!"
Okay?
♪♪ Rufus, you love to
watch football ♪♪
♪♪ On every day that it's
the television ♪♪
♪♪ But look into my eyes ♪♪
♪♪ We are getting married
♪♪ I forgot the other detail
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Jenny Slate, everybody.